good morning millennials happy wednesday
happy hump day
so exciting claude i know you're looking
forward to a day of humping how are you
doing um i totally forgot it was hump
day this truly changes everything that's
what i love about the morning toast is
that you're never gonna finish an
episode and not know what day it is yeah
no that's what you can expect here at
tmt just always letting you know what
day of the week it is i feel like it's a
really good positive wednesday so far
this week has been
really
kind to us i feel what do you think yeah
i mean things were a little chaotic this
morning just woke up my computer doesn't
turn on but that's what i love about
being at brian's he's a media mogul
entrepreneur
he had a spare computer a spare ring
light like i think my actual video now
is gonna be the best it's ever been
because brian literally opened this
computer out of the box like it was
brand new he's like yeah here take it
the feeling of getting a new computer i
personally hadn't experienced it in
about five years and i'm a brand new
person it's like my my mental hard drive
is clean my retina display is on point
i'm just i'm really feeling this and
it's really making working so much more
fun because i'm like oh i have to work
but i can pick up my new computer to do
it
you know what you're right your retina
display like is on fleek yeah no that's
what they say to me that's what they've
been saying that's what they're saying
about me like in the streets oh that's
the feedback yeah they're like
retina on point
so that's all you can ask for
[Laughter]
um well i hope everyone had a great
tuesday our show was like so chaotic so
long today's gonna be just as long
hopefully not as chaotic we do have deer
toasters today which we did postpone
from yesterday just to remind you guys
and to remind you guys about our new
segment i haven't actually checked the
email so i don't know if we got a lot of
submissions because i'm like the worst
podcaster on the planet but if you
haven't unburdened yourself yet head
over to unburdenyourselves gmail.com and
then burden us with some of your most
embarrassing things so that we can help
you help us yeah whatever's weighing on
you let it off your chest
and we will be here to support you we
don't judge really sometimes we do but
most of the time we try a little a
little bit but it just depends it
depends if it was like a hit and run two
times remember that
sorry i do um also so yesterday i i'm so
caught up i've never been like so caught
up on my tv ever like i finished summer
house so good we're finally getting into
like the paige and craig of it all i
finished um drag race i watched new
jersey last night obviously which we'll
discuss in the tv recap the season
premiere the premiere episode that you
and i were edited out of oh my god we
were texting about a million things last
night so i i when i finally saw that the
fact that like margaret's pride party
just was
edited as a footnote in time i was about
to tell you and be like pride question
mark but
i we were just talking about a million
things i didn't have a chance to
okay but there was so much footage like
in the this seas coming this season and
it's from that party but i guess we're
just you know
edited out not relevant
no well we knew that we knew what's
interesting
we knew that what's interesting is that
the promo photo they've been using for
the new season which features like i
think it's melissa jackie and teresa is
from margaret's pride party brian kelly
and pasta fazel are in the background of
that photo i am there too but i am too
short to be seeing them right behind
teresa giudice so they're using that
promo pic though they're not actually
showing the event in which the pic was
taken therefore false advertising we
should sue like those people who are
suing anna to armis oh my god that's a
really good point that happens all the
time with bravo they like give us a
scene in a preview and then it never
comes to fruition let's see how the
honest arma stands um do with their suit
and then maybe we'll follow suit
right maybe they'll set some legal
precedent for us yeah but it was fun to
see the gang back together i mean
new jersey it's always fun when a new
franchise premieres and you just like
remember how much you love everyone but
i feel that way especially with new
jersey because of my love my undying
love for margaret joseph's and it's just
like every time there's a new season and
i also feel that way like about melissa
and joe and i i just me too it was a
pleasure to see them back on my screen i
didn't realize how much i needed them
and how much i missed them
my theory is that i think a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happens in the second half of their
filming schedule and so stuff from the
beginning just got cut out that's what i
think okay that's fair i mean get to cut
to the chase and you know what if we i
wasn't in the mood to like watch a whole
evening and like knowing i wasn't going
to be in any footage because i'm too
short and i'm too shy and i didn't do
anything interesting with myself
yeah no i like how we're talking about
like this party as if we were even
remotely relevant when you know we sat
in the corner eating tacos like we did
nothing yeah exactly and that was like
the first week that i knew i was
pregnant so i really wasn't like doing
anything interesting just like trying to
stay totally
and not tell people you know
yeah yeah
and now look how far we've come okay i
guess that actually shows that this
season was filmed this last night's
episode was nine months ago
because i was trying to figure out when
yeah no i was trying to figure out like
when it was from it was nice to see just
like fun summer vibes
it feels like it's just i was actually
thinking
teresa's party like looked really fun
[Music]
like the the setting looked fun
but the yes like having a pool party to
go to with lots of food and drink like
that sounds fun right now yeah but the
mood was just off
off agreed
okay and you know what i found to be i
mean i don't want to yeah we'll spoil
the recap but i just want to say frank
catania having a girlfriend is shocking
to me i don't know it's her fault it's
wrong it shouldn't be happening and if
it is then this woman must be an
incredible woman i would have liked to
meet her and she should be on the show
because she must be stand up she must be
so utterly fantastic to have wooed a man
like frank
a stand-up gal
yeah
i totally agree that was just a
curveball
we will preserve the rest of our
thoughts for the tv recap segment
obviously because before that we've got
dear toasters we've got fast five and
honestly i just think we have so much on
our docket i don't really have much to
update everyone on like i think we
should just dive in
we should dive in plus i have another
doctor's appointment today so i'm
running a tight schedule plus we're
recording the redheads today make sure
you submit your questions for the
redheads to the redheads book club at
gmail.com even if it's not a question i
would like to know your thoughts on the
book if you have some interesting
thoughts so hit us up we're gonna how
was
how was my doctor's appointment
yesterday
yes
it was good you know it's crazy they
have this new technology when you get a
sonogram that you can see uh 3d where
they like sort of make it look like an
image not just the black and white
footage and i've gotten to use it a few
times over the past few months when i've
gone to the doctor but like baby's
always hiding and it's not like as so
premium sometimes but yesterday i got
some really cool footage
and
that
that made it all worthwhile but it was
just a chaotic morning for me yesterday
like everything that could go wrong did
i remember huh
yeah but anyways it's all very exciting
so uh i guess without further ado so i
can make it on time to this doctor's
appointment because we respect your
medical
uh prioritization yeah because i i was
late yesterday
yeah they called me when i was on my way
which is like i get so much anxiety when
i'm late and i don't [ __ ] leave the
house so like the one time in two weeks
that i'm leaving the house and i'm not
even on time i just there's no excuse no
none
so now without further ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
little spoon little spoon is a one-stop
shop for healthy easy meal time and
snack time for your baby toddler and big
kids delivered straight to your door
little spoon makes everything fresh and
uses absolutely nothing artificial it's
just like homemade and it's all
delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop your meals in the fridge or
freezer and use them when you're ready
it's literally that easy i just think
conceptually little spoon is a great
concept for a brand because of course
when you have a baby you have tons of
different like dietary needs and you
have to shop at a million different
places but little spoon makes it easy
because they're taking care of all the
kids in your family not just the babies
they've got the toddlers they've got the
teenagers all of their recipes taste
amazing and they're nutritionally
balanced and free of junk so you're
helping to set your little ones up for a
lifetime of health
i've tried a lot of their foods um i
know you have a lot of the baby foods
but i have a lot of the big kid food and
it's really good like really delicious
so easy to make you know i'm not
i'm no rachel ray and it's it's
something i can handle so i think that
that means most people can handle it as
well no it's it's a brilliant idea
and i'm so glad that the execution is so
on
the best part is that the price is right
with kids meal just under five dollars
and baby food and smoothie snacks under
three dollars
it's trying to make just a little spoon
a little easy start the new year with
little spoon get 50 off your first order
with code toast at checkout the the code
is toast t-o-a-s-t at check out to get
50 off your first little spoon order
which is pretty substantial in my
opinion and a deal you're just not gonna
want to miss out on
great we love little spoon it is camper
tested counselor approved
today's episode is also brought to you
by honey thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart so here's how it works imagine
you're shopping online as most of us do
on a daily basis when you go to check
out the honey button will drop down and
all you have to do is press apply
coupons wait a few seconds honey will
search for coupons and find the best one
and apply it to your cart and you just
like literally watch your total checkout
balance go down it's magical there's no
reason not to do it honey is so easy to
use it's free to download and it just
saves you money like i just don't
understand why anyone would hear this
and say oh no i don't want that because
why wouldn't you
i've saved on and by the way like the
they work on so many brands like i've
saved on makeup on food on like
electronics there's nothing honey can't
save you money on so if you don't
already have it you are straight up
missing out and by getting it you're
just going to do yourself favor
um when you go to
joinhoney.com
toast so if you want to download it for
free it's a browser extension go to
joinhoney.com
toast joinhoney.com toast i just don't
think you'll regret it i really don't oh
no i don't know how you could it's
saving you money with honey it's such a
wonderful extension
yes honey
okay let's get into the stories we have
a lot to talk about today the first
story which is the follow-up from
yesterday whoopi goldberg has been
suspended from the view following the
holocaust comments that she made saying
it was not about race abc news president
kim godwin tweeted effective immediately
i am suspending whoopi goldberg for her
wrong and hurtful comments well whoopi
has apologized i've asked her to take
time to reflect and learn about the
impact of her comments
this is surprising to be honest like
yeah but
i don't know i think this like sucks
like i think i don't think this was the
right decision yes i don't think it was
the right decision either when i saw it
it just like doesn't feel right it
doesn't again like it's
how is this productive whatsoever i
guess we won't be getting our our
holocaust education week at the view
no it's not productive and like i think
even though this statement from kim
feels very stern like we are taking a
stance goodbye i actually think for
whoopi and like to minimize the scandal
this is like the best outcome for her
she gets two weeks off like
when she comes back you know the world
moves so fast no one will have
remembered this like we'll all just move
on and there's really no um
teachable moment like i know i watched
her on colbert and then i watched her
intro to yesterday's episode and i just
wasn't feeling warm and fuzzy about it
not that she said anything wrong it was
just like a vibe like i just i
personally didn't find it to be like the
most sincere thing that was ever said on
the planet so i don't know it just feels
like she did the bare minimum and now
she gets two weeks off and she'll come
back and we all forget about it where i
don't and honestly i don't believe in
cancer culture like i don't believe in
somebody saying something wrong and
instead of you know
talking about it doing holocaust
education day on the view we're just
gonna shut her down make her stay in her
house for two weeks i just don't think
it's productive and i don't think that
it really teaches a lesson here to be
honest yeah i think it'll be two weeks
to flatten the curve though for sure
[Laughter]
i just i don't know i think this is the
wrong move like 100 i think this like
kind of sucks like it's it's not even
like they're making a statement like
we're firing whippy no they're not doing
like really anything except kind of
letting her off the hook let let it
diffuse let her you know get her
bearings and then come back so not only
are they not really making a statement
they're also not helping the situation
like there is a problem in our country
about like holocaust education so just
shutting the conversation down for two
weeks really doesn't help anyone it
doesn't help whoopee it doesn't help us
it doesn't have the jewish community it
doesn't help the view audience i think
this could have been handled better and
i don't believe in like shutting people
down i believe in guiding them through
the process
i could not agree with you more i think
you have said everything that i'm
thinking and i really have nothing
further to add this to me is just oh my
god am i a genius yeah no i have no
further comment
really
yeah like
and
i don't know i just when i heard it i
was actually surprised first of all i'm
like oh my god like
i don't know because i think as a i
think a lot of jews can relate to like
you feel like sometimes like people
don't really acknowledge anti-semitism
so to see this conversation being had
like i actually am really relieved
because
it's like the jews biggest nightmare for
people like forget about the holocaust
or minimize the holocaust so for us it
was a really big deal what she said and
i don't know i just feel like we really
could have used this as like a very
public teachable moment for holocaust
education and not only we're not getting
that we're getting like the opposite
yeah i totally completely agree
and i did watch colbert when she's like
stop writing me and it was rude like it
was it wasn't the you know face and tone
of someone who understands how deeply
she's hurt a community with deep rooted
generational trauma like i just don't
think she understood that so no i was
disappointed in her and i just would
have would have loved to have seen you
know
a
a coming together moment and we're not
getting that so this is
we're getting two weeks to let it die
down
it's really two weeks to flatten the
curve honestly
literally yeah to flatten the curve and
that never works
no we know it never works never works
yeah so whatever
yeah whatever
let's move on to our next story which is
like a strange twist in this adele story
adele vs las vegas
so adele has been holed up with rich
paul after a volatile romance added to
vegas drama so sources are saying this
is coming from page six that their
volatile relationship allegedly
contributed to the cancellation of her
las vegas residency after she
dramatically canceled her dates at
caesar's palace causing an outcry from
fans the singer went straight home
straight to the nba manager's beverly
hills home and has remained there ever
since insiders say the pair have been
trying to fix things and paul is helping
her renegotiate her contract with the
vegas casino owners um a source also
said she and rich had been fighting and
their relationship was volatile before
she cancelled her dates
apparently like while she was rehearsing
she was shouting and sobbing over the
phone a source said adele's been crying
and couldn't get through a single full
rehearsal for the past month just
constantly on the phone with rich loudly
shouting and sobbing
and also it was reported i don't know if
we even spoke about this yeah keith
urban is replacing her which personally
i'm thrilled about like i will be going
yeah no that sounds really fun but that
makes it even more permanent i was still
holding out hope like okay weekend with
adele it won't be this weekend it'll be
next weekend but no it's over
and i think this is really like a
stain on her otherwise
impeccably perfect pristine career
and to know that it's like
perhaps about relationship drama is
really surprising considering everything
we've been hearing from her in the last
few months is like this is the season of
her life like this is the relationship
you know that's
helping her be exactly who she is and
she's so happy and you just don't like
shout and stop on the phone during work
all the time when you're so happy in
your relationship
so i mean when we recapped it we did say
there's definitely much more going on
and obviously we were right i don't know
if this is 100 the truth but adele did
then like post on instagram yesterday
her caption was hi i'm really happy to
say that i'm performing at the brits
next week and also i'll be popping in to
see graham for a chat on the couch while
i'm in town also i'm looking forward to
it oh and rich sends his love heart so
almost like a very subtle way of
acknowledging some of the rumors and
maybe perhaps trying to dispel them i
don't know if i i don't know if i
believe this page six thing
wholeheartedly i do think adele is going
through some stuff and there's like it
wasn't about covid it wasn't and we just
live in a world where like you can
literally get away with anything by
blaming [ __ ] on covet it's like it's
like kind of nice everyone has like a
perfect excuse but
i don't know if i believe the
the extent of this page six article but
there's somewhere in the middle of
what's actually going on
yeah i agree perhaps it's like she was
calling him on the phone shouting and
sobbing like about the show not
necessarily about things between them
though a second vegas source industry
insider said that it was there was
chatter about why he wasn't in vegas to
support adele
even like the day before the show was
supposed to launch but he's a busy man
so again like everything kind of seems
like there could be an explanation or
this could be the truth i think there's
probably something amiss here in general
but uh i also think you know the
tabloids like to do what they do
and like for me personally i would have
loved to have seen adele but like i just
wasn't gonna pay the premium that
the tickets were at and now just knowing
it's keith urban and i can most likely
like afford a really good seat that
makes me feel really good and i'm
personally grateful to rich to adele and
to keith
are you really gonna go
why not i [ __ ] love keith urban okay
right before the pandemic
right before the pandemic you and i were
planning a trip to vegas to see kelly
clarkson and we were also working on
getting tickets to keith urban's
residency which both of which we never
got to see so now like i'm just making
up for lost time and i love keith urban
like i definitely would go and support
i mean thinking about
the weekend we had planned to see kelly
clarkson in las vegas that was just
going to be like the peak of my life
like my favorite
person in my favorite city
and that was all just like ripped out
from under us like i
i'm angry
i'm angry about it it's a pipe it was a
pipe dream like it was we were never
going like we i mean it's so and we were
also going to go to the acm awards like
that weekend like when you think of all
the things that kova took from us all
personally like that is at the top of
the list i don't think about it enough
but now that i'm thinking about that
particular weekend especially the acms
and actually i was just looking at my
timehop and i was
two years ago i was trying on like
dresses in my apartment for the acms and
actually the dress i was um
the dress i bought for it i wore to a
wedding this summer the blue dress
everyone knows
um and it was just like there was so
much hope so much promise
and what's like so traumatizing about
that weekend as well obviously i just
want to say like obviously worse things
happened because of covet like we're
just being dramatic but the worst for me
was i was the one who put all the kelly
clarkson tickets on my credit card and
you know it took me over a year to get
refunded literally over a year
not not by me for everyone and then ever
and then everyone was supposed to pay no
no no re refunded from ticketmaster oh
oh
okay but did you i hadn't asked everyone
to pay me for the tickets yet oh okay
interesting it's yeah that's confusing
because like we were still planning the
weekend i was gonna like add up all the
you know i love to do that get the
points put everything on my credit card
and then send everyone a venmo request
like the hotels the flights like i do
everything so i put
eight kelly clarkson like front row
tickets on my credit card
literally never got the money back until
a year later because they kept
postponing the show like you would hold
on to your ticket and like when they
figured it out but then like a year
later they're like all right the show's
never happening like let's give everyone
their money back yeah exactly damn
and
that's hard to think about that's hard
to swallow but we're gonna pivot to our
next story because it's some exciting
news
i think
mickey guyton has been announced as the
super bowl 2022 national anthem singer
grammy-nominated singer mickey guyton
will perform the national anthem at the
2022 super bowl at sofi stadium she said
look at god i am shook i am grateful i
am praise dancing so excited to be
singing the national anthem at sblvi on
february 13th
that is i'm always for those who don't
know
yeah oh i was just gonna say for those
who don't know she's an incredibly
talented up-and-coming country artist
and like you're gonna be quaking her
voice is
really special like she the thing is
with the super bowl national anthem like
they can't just choose anyone because
there's a lot of people out here in
hollywood like who have record deals and
are very famous who can't carry a tune
if their life depended on it so not
everyone can do it star spangled banner
is also an extremely difficult song to
sing in terms of range not you know any
human being could just do it you know i
can obviously but
i think this is a great choice
i think it's a great choice i'm always
so interested to see who's going to sing
the national anthem at the super bowl
it's so prestigious and it's like
this you know singing that song at that
venue live
it will it separates the boys from the
men you know and you get to see a
perfect true talent and i think that
most of the time they really go with
people who are truly talented because it
will expose you it could ruin your
career fergie
oh of course yeah and fergie was at the
all-star game which is like a big stage
but it's not nearly as big as the super
bowl national anthem yeah and if the
national anthem at the super bowl like
doesn't give me goosebumps or make me
cry i'm sorry it's a failure
i completely agree and mickey guyton i
think will do like a really really good
job i suggest people like learn about
her music her song black like me is
literally
so good um so like indulge stream before
but i have the utmost faith in her
favorite super bowl um
national anthem performance like what's
the one you go back and watch on youtube
that like gives you chills oh i don't i
mean we did this a while ago where we
watch them all i mean obviously whitney
houston's is the most iconic and like
that's not even fair to say but i'm
trying to think of like of ones i
watched live recently and like how they
made me feel i mean when we went to the
super bowl
pink saying the national anthem and i
was like bawling but i was also kind of
hungover kind of extremely so just
feeling like really emotional and that
just really stuck with me
okay do you want me to read you who has
done it in recent years
yeah sure
okay
so in 1967 no i'm kidding
i was like no we don't have time i have
a doctor's appointment
in 2021 was eric church and jasmine
sullivan remember he played the guitar
and she sang
okay not memorable sorry
2020 demi lovato she can she can carry a
tune honestly like
yeah she can but again i don't remember
it
um 2019 was gladys knight
oh i remember that that was good
2018 was pink that's when we were there
luke bryan was 2017 which i don't
remember that's kind of weird yeah i
don't
remember gaga16 adina menzel 2015. you
know what i kind of loved kelly clarkson
did it in 2012. oh my god i've got to go
back and watch i really loved gaga's
actually because she was kind of like
off the charts in in a like
not in a musical way like in a um
emotional way like she was just like
giving everything like so much it was so
extra she put her own flare on it but i
think that she pulled it off i really
enjoyed that one
she also played the piano while she did
it which is just like incredibly
impressive like on the world's biggest
stage yeah that was a very very good one
and then that set her up beautifully to
do the halftime show the following year
exactly exactly so i'm really excited
about this i'm excited for the super
bowl so much entertainment obviously we
have the bangles and the rams
and then we have this halftime show
that's really like a mini music festival
this halftime show has like a trailer
for it they're really putting a lot into
the entertainment for the super bowl so
i will hopefully will be entertained
yeah and i've recently become like a
huge mary j blige fan because of her
song doubt that literally changed my
life and yesterday i actually watched
her amazon original documentary it was
very good like i first of all had no
idea how she like came up it's her story
it's crazy she recorded there used to be
these like booths at the mall she grew
up in yonkers so there used to be these
booths at the mall where you could go
and like record yourself singing and
they'll give you a cassette
and she did that and like it just the
cassette got passed around to a few
people the next thing you know like this
guy from a record label like shows up at
her apartment it was a crazy story and
the documentary was really good oh when
is the documentary from is it recent
i i mean i hadn't even heard that it had
come out i was just looking for
something to watch while dinner was
being made last night and i stumbled
upon it it's relatively recent because
she looks like she looks now um it was
celebrating the 25th anniversary of her
album my life which i think is the album
that like really changed
her life
very very cool
that'll be so it'll be good it'll yeah
that will be good okay are you ready for
our next story by the way
what i can't even watch a super bowl
because i have a show tickets available
at girlsnowjob.comtour
so thank you to everyone in boston who
bought tickets to the second show who
actually doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
super bowl um
you're a real one
yeah that's really funny our next story
i'm so obsessed with i
i can't like it's the most exciting news
i've ever heard
there is a new dating show coming to nbc
that is the bachelor meets downton abbey
it is called the courtship and it's
coming in march so listen to this the
courtship which was formerly titled
pride and prejudice and experiment in
romance announced their march 6th
premiere date as viewers first learned
last july the show centers around a
woman who was quote looking for her duke
and will subsequently embark on the
ultimate social experiment in romance to
do so taking a page out of bridgerton
the courtship will follow a group of
eligible hopeful suitors they'll be
trans transported to a regency-style
england home as they compete to win the
heart of the heroine and her court
peacock said housed in a castle on the
countryside set on a beautiful backdrop
of rolling hills the heroine and suitors
will experience that with which dreams
are made they will be immersed in a time
traveling quest for love as they
participate in activities including
carriage rides boat rides archery and
crafting handwritten letters for
communication at the end of the
competition the leading lady and her
contenders will discover if this
experience will bring them true love
it's giving medieval times i like it
it's like cosplaying right yeah it's the
bachelor but like set really at downton
abbey and they have to like go through
all of the old forms of courtship i
think this is such a cute idea
you know what it sounded weird but now
that i think about it i do think
actually you could
have success
dating wise on this show because like
you know with all social media and all
like the toxic things we have it makes
it really hard to date in this day and
age so kind of to pull that all the way
and go back to basics like sending a
message or a carrier pigeon like i don't
know i could see it
and also like on the bachelor the dates
whether they're going like atving or
jumping off of a building like they're
extremely distracting whereas i think
like these states carriage rides you
know maybe some pheasant shooting it
really makes it they
will facilitate i think a deeper bond
and even if none of that is true and
this woman like doesn't really find love
i think it will be highly entertaining
just to see people in the clothes and at
the houses and just doing these things
honestly i feel like this was made for
me i feel really seen right now target
demographic has been reached
yeah so i wonder if the snatcher will be
watching this i mean she would love it
too
but um is it going to be on cable or on
peacock i guess peacock which works for
me i'm into peacock yeah
yeah i don't currently pay for peacock i
literally like purchase it when i need
it and then i cancel it immediately
because like i don't consistently watch
stuff on there you know what i mean oh i
i'm not good about that i leave all of
my subscriptions running you know but i
also i'm very you know i don't just
subscribe to everything so if i'm going
to it needs to be something worthwhile
but then i'm
i'm committed
i'm committed i'm not fit yeah like i
purchased
peacock with ultimate girl's trip and
then the second i finished it i canceled
the subscription and i haven't needed it
since so i'm glad i just saved myself
like 15 bucks until the courtship
premieres i just do hope that it's very
high budget and like the the
wardrobe and the sets like that it's not
it doesn't feel you know community
theater medieval times like i really
hope that it feels like you know julian
fellowes is there behind the screen
trying to facilitate love
right hopefully it doesn't feel like
they're just larping around england
yeah no that would be extremely
distressing to see
they would it would be like um
like concerning
and weird
when does the second season of love is
blind come out like i feel like the
first season was actually five years ago
i don't know
i haven't heard anything that's like i'm
i'm ready for it
yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story though
already already
is it the fifth and final story that's
brought to you by legacy box it is
legacy box is the easiest and safest way
to reclaim all the priceless footage you
haven't seen in years
send in your legacy box filled it with
aging vhs tapes camcorder tapes any home
videos you have like personally we grew
up in the vhs era and like years ago
when we were trying to like
watch them we couldn't figure out how
and legacy box truly came in save the
day it's the nicest thing you can do for
your family or your like grandma like to
revisit those memories is so special
and legacy box like could not make it
easier they do it
so professionally they keep you updated
the entire process
and their team will professionally
digitize everything by hand at their 110
000 square foot production campus in the
usa and you get everything back on a
thumb drive a dvd or the cloud i
remember we did the thumb drive
whatever's easiest for you
and there's just really no reason not to
do it it's a great thing to do for
someone as a gift if you don't want to
send it in now use our code get the
legacy box and then send it in when
you're ready um they can digitize up to
19 different types of consumer media
media from a vhs which is what we did to
super 8 film so they can do everything
visit legacybox.com toast to save 40 off
for a limited time order today claim the
exclusive offer for our listeners and
then send it in when you're ready if
you're not ready yet but just make sure
to get the 40 off at legacybox.com toast
to unlock 40 off today that's
legacybox.com
toast it's really like such a sweet
beautiful thing it really is it's one of
my favorite sponsors it's the gift that
keeps on giving and it's also just
something sponsor i get the most
messages about like what was the legacy
box code oh for sure but it's also
something that aside from a gift just
something that you should do and have
because it's like the otherwise that
stuff is like oh [ __ ] i have to go all
my vhs is out of the hard drive
yeah it weighs on you so unburden your
memories with legacy box
they should use that
our fifth and final story is a little
human interest weather news because it's
groundhog's day
and the groundhog
has seen his shadow and he has predicted
six more weeks of winter
he always [ __ ] predicts six more
weeks of winter
totally
and like i don't think anyone can really
think about groundhog's day
without thinking about the
and i just think it's worth mentioning
you know the groundhogs we lost
um that were murdered by our former
mayor bill de blasio i just think
perhaps we should have a moment of
silence for them agreed
i'm glad to see that this groundhog made
it out alive and he's just spreading
lies and propaganda and yeah and
misinformation
big big misinformation like i don't
claim
groundhog's day whatsoever also i know
what happens in new york but like is it
for the whole country like i don't
really get how groundhog's day works and
i feel like i'm having a groundhog's day
moment because we talk about this every
year no i don't think we've ever really
talked about groundhog's day and i feel
like i've never and if it wasn't for
just like trolling the daily mail today
i wouldn't have even seen
that you know uh punxsutawney phil did
see his shadow and then i also can never
remember like okay if you saw it does
that mean six more weeks does that mean
less weeks right but it's also never
good news from from the groundhog
eternal pessimist
no and also if he sees his shadow
doesn't that mean it's sunny outside
there for less winter
see i don't know i don't know the whole
thing i once
i wonder how far into like
you know the future we have to get
before we're like this is trash
this is a bad idea people were done with
this moronic tradition literally yeah it
goes back to 1887. so that's kind of
sweet that you know we've been carrying
the torch since 1887 and that the
groundhogs because otherwise you know
the groundhogs would get no play except
for if you're watching caddyshack
so
i think wait for groundhog appreciation
and awareness it's it's nice
so they've been doing it since 1887 and
the groundhog since 1887 has been called
punxsutawney phil so they just keep
replacing the groundhog and
giving it the same name is what you're
saying which is hella disrespectful yeah
exactly and a little fun fact is
punxsutawney phil has predicted winter
105 times and did not see his shadow and
predicted shorter winter only 20 times
eternal pessimists this phil
i mean i'm sorry that literally makes no
sense i didn't see my shadow like who
came up with this moronic idea i don't
know
i don't know and furthermore
i don't even want to know what happens
to the groundhogs the other 364 days a
year like new york is the most
mismanaged disgusting like
a country city and like i just know that
those groundhogs are not being taken
care of like i don't think they have you
know stunning facilities with
round-the-clock care and it makes me sad
to think that they are like you know
born into captivity for our pleasure for
this dumb ass
tradition
yeah
yeah
agreed but it's really weird what i said
when you think about it long and hard
like it's just so
weird
bizarre agreed bizarre but it's you know
tradition and it ties us
throughout the last
125 years so 40
40.
1887 it's 20 21.
eight yeah yeah i think somewhere in
between us oh jesus okay oh am i better
at math than you
i don't know hold on i'm getting my
calculator calculator it's 20 22. it's
actually 2022. 135.135
[ __ ] and i said 40. i'm literally a
genius well i have pregnancy brains so
i'm off the hook
fair fair my brain really actually i
think the more shocking part is that i
got it right not that you got it wrong
you know yeah no i've never claimed math
to be my strong suit and there have been
moments but i don't know if it's
pregnancy brain but i guess just as
pregnancy just makes you really
exhausted where like my brain really
feels so scrambled i even feel like when
i'm reaching for words on this show i'm
just not finding the words that i'm
looking for and maybe that is the best
screen
yeah
yeah i feel that
um okay well so let's we have dear
toasters and tv recap which we do first
i think your toasters so that everyone
can listen because i don't know if
everyone watched real housewives
you're such a genius okay ready to your
toasters
and by the way we have one update today
two submissions and one update
hello jackie claudia and crow let's get
right into this one a little backstory i
have a very close-knit family three
older sisters who i've always looked up
to and admired and also relevant i've
been married to my husband for two years
but we've been together for ten he is a
p john and i've only ever gotten the
impression that my family loves him so i
was snooping through my mom's phone for
reasons unrelated to this story i know i
shouldn't have been i deeply regret it
and i found a text from my oldest sister
from when my mom tested positive for
kovid my mom said i think sam my husband
is most worried about getting it since
he is the only one in the family who
hasn't and by the way he's worried about
getting it because i'm 35 weeks pregnant
and he's terrified he will miss the
birth of our first child my spis
my sister responded you should spit in
his drink he deserves it
oh
honestly i'm at a loss for words not
only am i shocked that my sister has
some sort of ill will for my husband but
that's a horrible thing to say like
truly what the [ __ ] who says something
like that can you imagine if one of your
sisters said that about your husband i'm
heartbroken part of me wants to keep
quiet about it because if my husband
found out he would be devastated but the
other part is of me is fuming and hurt
and wants to tell her to [ __ ] off it's
such a vile thing to say i could never
imagine saying that about someone even
if i hated them i honestly don't know if
confronting her will bring any
resolution i can't see her owning up to
saying
yeah i don't like him because of x y and
z i more so see her brushing it off and
saying she was joking my family is more
so the type to sweep things under the
rug i want to ask my mom about it but i
don't know if i've lost the right to do
so since i was snooping what would you
do sincerely a sad and angry toaster
before you give advice because i truly
have nothing to say here this is the
most horrible thing i've ever read in my
life um i do think the main takeaway and
lesson for everyone listening should be
like you really
especially to your mom like that is so
not i don't want to shame you because i
know you're like in a pickle right now
but to snoop through anyone's phone it's
like a huge invasion of privacy to snoop
through your mother's phone
is such a high level of disrespect like
and i'm sorry that you found out
something that hurt you but like that's
what you get for invading your mother's
privacy that's all i'll say this is why
we stand anti-snoop here at the morning
toast because you find things out that
you don't want to know that you aren't
meant to know and this is one of those
things and it's clear that you've taken
away this lesson and i'm sure it won't
happen again but let this be a caution
to all this is why we don't snoop unless
we have caused you unless it's like you
know you think your man is really out
there cheating and like
you have real
evidentiary support and aside from that
you don't just snoop for snooping's sake
because then you fight you will find
something that's going to hurt your
feelings and here you go this is it now
what to do we're at this in fl we're at
this crossroads if the snooping has been
done and you know this harmful
information
i don't know how you could just like not
do anything about it i don't think you
need to say anything to your mom
i
i would say your mom didn't say anything
your sister did right right exactly so
like i this is between you and your
sister
and
you could wait until like she gives you
a vibe that she doesn't like your
husband so maybe she's been giving you
this vibe and you just never picked up
on it but you could keep your eye out
for it and then confront her when you
have you know evidence that you didn't
get illegally
that you can say
why are you talking like this
know do you not like my right if this is
how she truly feels there will be
another opportunity where she makes a
snide remark and maybe you were
oblivious to it then but now you are not
and your opportunity will come i don't
think you're going to fix it also you're
35 weeks pregnant i would focus on other
things like if your husband is like
truly a p john
then you guys have nothing to worry
about enjoy the rest of your pregnancy
this will like give you stress and
stress is not good for a baby you will
figure this out later truly
yeah i would i would table it for now um
even though that's really [ __ ] shitty
no like if i read something like you
were like talking like i'm gonna spin
men's drink i would be like shook
yeah no that would be so
that would be so weird it's also agreed
like a baseline like a crazy way to
phrase something about someone you don't
like let's poison them with coven like
it's crazy
yeah i don't know how you can ask it
without showing even though like okay so
you snooped it's not a big deal like you
could say like i was doing something on
mom's phone and i saw this text like
what does it mean
but
i don't know at 35 weeks pregnant i
would just wait for the next opportunity
and just focus on your your immediate
home agreed 100
um okay here's the next one hello
jackson claude thanks for keeping me
laughing all quarantined i couldn't have
gotten through without my daily dose of
toast thanks girl
i'm running in with quite the
predicament over the weekend i had some
friends over and their husbands and we
were all just casually drinking hanging
out my husband is out of town for work
all month long story short after
everyone had passed out on my couch and
went home including my best friend sally
her husband started getting super flirty
and holding my hand and cuddling me oh
my god
note it's not uncommon for sally's
husband to stay out after she goes home
since she's a grandma and goes to bed at
eight o'clock lol i kept telling him i
didn't want to cross this line and
avoided eye contact with him
where he'd try to make a move he kept
telling me how he wishes he'd see me
more and how we have a mutual attraction
to each other which yeah he's cute but i
would never act on it is it ironic that
me and sally look eerily similar but
that's besides the point nothing
happened i've had the biggest pit for
days now i can't sleep i can't eat i
have elevated blood pressure i feel this
guilt which i'm not positive why because
nothing happened do i tell my husband
and then causes awkward tension in the
friend group and risk him potentially
confronting sally's husband do i tell
sally do i just let the pit pass and
take this to my grave we're moving away
in a few months so my plan is just to
avoid him as best as i can but any other
advice you have is greatly appreciated i
view sally as a lifelong friend and i'm
just worried about losing her
oh this is so tough it depends what kind
of girl sally is is she the type of girl
who would receive this information in a
positive way and be like wow thank you
so much for telling me my husband's an
enormous piece of [ __ ] i had no idea or
is she going to be defending me like
well your shirt was like really low cut
and like maybe that's why you know no
well she would just be like no he didn't
like you're reading it wrong like it's
not about you don't flatter yourself
yeah i don't know we got to get a read
on what type of gal sally is what type
of galley but definitely tell your
husband because i wouldn't want you to
be like to get first of all unburning
yourself to your husband is just clearly
weighing on you like this is a big
dynamic in your friend group and um
that's something that like you shouldn't
have to deal with by yourself so share
it with him and also that way if
something does like happen later on like
he has been kept abreast all along and
you guys are teammates you're on the
same side like he should
know all the information don't tell him
to do anything or you know like nothing
happened whatever but just like let him
know that's how you're feeling
um
and then on the sally front it's yeah
you have to you have to know sally take
her temperature
and see if you think that like this
would
be information that she would even
know what to do with or she wants to use
it to push you away
yeah it's a secret part though that
makes it seem like you have a pit i
think because you're keeping it a secret
like as if you did something wrong which
you didn't but keeping something in like
just makes you feel icky so i agree with
jackie like definitely tell your husband
like 100
and then use your your judgment trust
your gut on what you think to do with
sally because we don't know sally um and
they're just girls out there who don't
want to know and there are girls out
there who do and which type of girl is
sally is she like other girls or is she
not like other girls that's up to you to
decide
yeah
yeah and
hopefully that was helpful
yeah i think it was i think for the
first half definitely tell your husband
maybe he maybe he
has he knows sally better than he do
maybe he has a pov that could be helpful
here don't you play him this episode and
then let him know what le like what he
thinks
yeah
okay our third and final one is an
update from someone who wrote in really
recently okay so jackie and claudia as a
toaster of my word i am back with an
update you read my submission to dear
toasters on january 25th for a refresher
literally like last week all right i'm
the girl whose boyfriend was sexting
other women and sending dick pics to his
gay friends and then trying to convince
me it was normal remember
yes
ladies when claudia started reading my
deer toaster submission i was elbows
deep cleaning this guy's dirty dishes at
his apartment i'm a sucker for a charmer
i guess
because i just decided to just let it go
because he was going to turn over a new
leaf but listening to you guys read my
email and hearing your responses was the
validation i needed to let myself feel
how i was truly feeling about the
situation instead of being blinded by
his presentation of it thank you guys
for helping me to be honest with myself
about the situation while i'm sad to
have let the relationship go it feels
good to stand up for myself and value
myself a grateful toaster thank you oh
that's tough to hear i mean but
sometimes you really do need to hear the
perspective of someone who has
absolutely no horse in the race to kind
of jolt you because you'll convince
yourself of anything when you really
want to make something work so i'm glad
we could be that for you i'm really
sorry that it didn't work out but you
will be so grateful in the long run like
a hundred percent
and i also think that even just hearing
what you wrote but us reading it just if
you it might like stop you in your
tracks and you're able to like hear your
own story in your own words but like
from a little bit of a further perch
and just being able to see it in that
light
is probably really helpful um i wish you
luck obviously this is a very a fresh
breakup so i i do wish you luck in this
journey and you know it'll get
harder before it gets easier but please
keep us posted on what comes next for
you i have enormous respect for you it's
very hard to make changes like this in
your life and
i wish you all the best
and you know what you probably did this
man a favor too because it seems like he
has a lot to figure out about you know
what's going on in his life perhaps his
sexuality and you've now given him the
space to do that so it feels like we all
won here even though everyone in the
probably feels like terrible in the end
you're all winners
yes and you no longer have to do his
dirty dishes
right
um okay let's talk about the real
housewives of new jersey premiere last
night which was very good and is brought
to you by
give me a moment
single drunk female samantha fink is a
person in progress and being a person is
super hard single drunk female is the
new free-form original series now
streaming on hulu it's from the
executive producer of girls and the
executive producer of russian doll
samantha used to get drunk all the time
but now she's getting clean and it's
gonna get real messy fresh out of rehab
samantha's forced to move back home live
with her mom who she affectionately
calls smother she's working at her local
grocery store taking naps in the cereal
aisle and going to meetings sam's taking
sobriety one day at a time
but those days they just keep on coming
with her former drinking buddy and newly
found friends of the program by her side
sam is trying to make the most of her
second chance a chance to start over a
chance to be a slightly better person
a chance at love because when you start
at rock bottom the only place to go is
up check out the new dramedy that is
sure to make you laugh even if sometimes
it's just to keep from crying freeform's
single drunk female also streaming on
hulu right now free forms single drunk
female
all right the real housewives of new
jersey great to see the gang back
together we've got a new gal
uh tracy johnson who's married to tiki
barber who joe gorga has like the
biggest crush on um it was great i agree
with you it was great to see the ladies
for me personally i mean most of the
drama is like still
continued from last season nothing like
crazy happened except for the video
um
but for me like the big shocker of the
episode like something i actually could
not get past was jennifer going to
turkey to get her nose done when her
husband is literally a plastic surgeon
like i don't understand
i don't understand i mean i understand
that bill like doesn't want to work on
her again but you know if you're going
to do your no which is such a big like
part of your
physical presence your face like it's
just crazy or maybe if he doesn't want
to work with her like someone else in
his practice or a buddy of his but to
like have a plastic surgeon for her
husband and to go on instagram to find
your next plastic surgeon was um
incredibly surprising i felt the same
way yeah there's a lot i mean it's so
weird i had no idea there's all this
stuff with jennifer and bill obviously
to skip to the end like margaret drops a
bomb that
bill had an affair
well if you remember at the last reunion
they were like alluding to a lot of
weirdness about bill they never outright
said like what it was but just like
skeletons etc so i guess margaret is
bringing that same energy
into this season and you know what i
actually really like margaret for doing
that because that happens a lot on
housewives it reminds me of gisele
bryant like there's always people who
are so in other people's business and
always likes you know bringing up
[ __ ] that happens off camera [ __ ] from
people's past but then when it comes to
them it's like oh no you can't talk
about me and jennifer gives like that
giselle bryan energy and it's not fair
so you know what everyone really does
have skeletons and if if
um
if jennifer can go on and on saying
horrible things about margaret's mother
you know what margaret can say whatever
the [ __ ] she wants about jennifer's
husband sorry did you watch watch what
happens live last night
i did i was actually extremely surprised
by a lot of things yeah i didn't watch
the whole thing but i experienced one of
the most moronic moments um on
television when they asked the question
like did margaret go below the bell by
bringing up jennifer's and bill's affair
and
theresa was like yes of course she did
and andy obviously was like but you did
the same thing to jackie and she was
like no but that was a rumor this is
facts that's worse no so like spreading
something that is like true about
someone is better
than sharing the truth like i i can't i
can't
no i was extremely grateful for andy for
being
on top of that because i had totally
even forgotten about that but you know
teresa's just so transparent because if
it was the other way around she would
have said you know
jennifer didn't go below the belt she's
just so transparent she has no ethics
she has no backbone she just supports
people blindly she doesn't have like
principles that she upholds like it's so
stupid um
so i thought margaret was 100 justified
i did feel like um the girls were being
like a little mean about her nose which
obviously her nose does not look good
but she was in a cast like in the
previous scene it's obviously still
swollen like so i'm sure it was shocking
for her to like come out with a new nose
like not looking so great but i did
think they were being like a little mean
i agree that they were um and even just
like the energy you hate to see like
people ganging up on one person and
whenever that happens it just always
makes me you know feel sympathetic
towards the one person but
i think for margaret melissa and jackie
like these are very rational women and
they have put up with a lot over the
past few years and i think they're just
like making this decision to like freeze
jennifer out like we don't want this
person
on our show anymore like she says the
most atrocious things about us so i'm
still trying to come from that place
when i see them like and it's not even i
mean aside from the nose common it's not
even like they're being like actively
mean towards her it's just like we are
going to pretend like you're not here
because we don't want you to be here
which at this point after all that's
been said i i do understand
and it must be frustrating to film with
someone who like
you you'll have you know
you'll come to an agreement with someone
you'll apologize you'll hug and then
it's like the person walks away and it's
like it never happened it's actually
just frustrating and it's like you feel
like you're going crazy like jennifer's
always apologizing and then nothing
changes she goes back doubles down on
what she did and what she said so i
understand of course them not wanting to
be friends with her and honestly after
last season i was so done with her but i
just did feel like a little i'm a human
you know i felt bad her walking in
everyone ignoring her and then making
fun of her nose behind her back yeah i
agree i i i
and it feels like perhaps maybe when she
starts opening up about what's actually
going on in her life like that couldn't
be the uh conduit for a different kind
of relationship with the ladies and
until she does that you know they're
just like you're phony and you're mean
and you're lying and we don't have time
for you but like it seems like jackie
this season has a bit of a soft spot for
her considering like what she's going to
go through with bill and i do think that
does bring people together but when
you're like lying about your life and
also like just projecting onto other
people and starting like rumors about
them and trying to come between friends
yeah there's no space for friendship
here but i think if she humbles herself
which it seems like she's going to this
season
maybe there's a passion to friendship
yeah yeah so the bombshell was obviously
that bill aidan had a affair at his
previous practice with a pharmaceutical
rep which i just found to be shocking
just because i just don't see that from
bill and i've been like a bill stan um
and so i'm looking forward to diving
into that deeper but obviously the
center
the whole episode was centered around
this video of louis i remember when it
went viral but then when they were
referring to it on the episode i
couldn't remember for the life of me
what the video was and i just wish that
they showed it like i know it's probably
like a copyright thing or whatever i
could not it was just like frustrating
and it was
such a weird video when i rewatched it
on like i found it on twitter i was
cringing
but
it's definitely bizarre and requires you
know some explanation but i don't really
feel like
he's not you know committing a crime he
doesn't really owe anyone an explanation
except theresa
yeah but teresa's always in other
people's [ __ ] so
the reaction from the whole group i
hadn't i've never saw this video i
didn't even know what they were talking
about yeah i feel like anytime there's a
headline about like louie's past i don't
click it like i don't really care
so i never
yeah so you sent me the video last night
because i was like what [ __ ] video
and i can't have an opinion on this
until i've seen the video and yeah
that's bizarre um bob from the biggest
loser was on watch what happens live
last night
and not only would andy like cut him off
at every single turn did you realize
that anytime he was like sharing his
opinion and he was like
just shutting him down
okay i did realize that and i saw a
bunch of people being like wow andy
hates bob
but
bob has been on watch weapons live so
frequently that he should really know
better how it works he was being so
long-winded
talking over teresa when it like wasn't
his turn and andy has like a tight ship
to run it's a really quick show like and
bob should know better like andy does
cut a lot of people off a lot but it's
only because that's how the show like
runs and if it's their first time on
like maybe they don't know bob should
know better bob was actually being
annoying like sorry bob being like
chatty okay i actually didn't think he
was being long-winded i thought he was
talking quickly and with purpose and he
was saying stuff and andy was cutting
him off but i'm sure they're fine it's
just like when he has teresa and it's
like okay bob we don't really want to
hear from you but um then you have
someone else like you're literally an
extra at this point right but he did say
something interesting that made me think
about the video in a different
perspective because of course when i saw
it i was like what is this like culti
vibes but apparently like there are
these camps like these man camps where
these men go and like which is more like
a spiritual yeah camp it's a spiritual
retreat it's like camp toast and they
really like unburden themselves they get
really into it and um
just let their
emotions feelings out and i think if
you're someone who has done something
like that i've never even heard of
something like this but like
he was trying to like improve him better
himself and so i think seeing that yeah
out of context like is weird and bizarre
but if you like understood the whole
process maybe it would give you a better
sense of what he was trying to do there
um but because he won't address the clip
like we would never
know that so if it wasn't for bob harper
i would just be like why is he with his
friends on the beach but those people
probably weren't his friends he's
probably doing some like spiritual
probably just met them
yeah and this is like part of it so it
i'm trying not to judge really but i do
think he should have had a better
reaction on the show and just like
explained it to people not that he owes
anyone an explanation sure but just it
would have it could have been a nothing
burger and now it's going to be like
this big burger like
who's going to bring it up to teresa
when it doesn't really need to be like
that plus teresa for her part like has
you know a checkered past and i don't
think that she's judging anyone based on
what they've done in the past and
in the grand scheme of things making
like a weird emotional video like it's
not that big of a deal yeah no i
literally said like last night when we
were watching i'm like literally
teresa's been to prison i don't think
she's in any position to judge anyone
especially when like it's not like he's
doing a human sacrifice in the video
it's just like kind of cringy i agree
bob harper cleared it up for me in such
a quick and swift way but i do think him
and theresa is handling this really
poorly like thinking like they're trying
so hard to minimize it that it's only
making it bigger like just address it
and move on like we could literally the
more you act like it doesn't exist in
the words of erica jane the bigger [ __ ]
gets
yeah and also it seems like this season
teresa is kind of taking this path of
like i want to keep my relationship on
the download like i don't need to share
everything with the cameras but teresa
judice has made a deal with the devil of
reality television and she this whole
show centers around her she has given
everything to the show the show has
given everything to her and i don't
think she can just back out now and be
like i want my privacy you know
specifically 100 and her don't worry no
one's giving it to her no there's people
on other franchises you know if kathy
hilton says i'm not i'm not showing this
part of my life they're not showing that
part of her life but teresa is
real houses of new jersey this bravo
machine has you know supported her life
and her family for 10 years like there's
really no getting out of it now and i
don't think that you know
i don't think this will hold water
no me neither i do think it was very
cool to see gia giudice finally
bartending on watch what happens live i
guess i didn't realize she hasn't been
21 this whole time um and it was cute
they threw her like a little birthday
party it was very it was like a cute it
was actually a good episode of watch
weapons live and a pretty good premiere
yeah it was a good premiere um i like
the new housewife so far uh even though
we didn't really get to know her but it
seems like she has a good energy about
her and that's yeah she just seems like
exciting
yeah exactly and just like like easy
i do think like she has a major drama
and oh also i thought her background was
super interesting how like they met at
the today show she gave the timeline i
do think it was weird he left his wife
when she was eight weeks pregnant but
like she gave the timeline and then the
headlines like leaves for an intern when
she was like not an intern um i thought
that was interesting i actually would
like to know more about that whole
moment for them
yeah very very interesting
but she does have i think there's like
some something goes down with her and
tiki i'm not 100 sure but like she's at
the center of some drama at some point
oh interesting
and then the other point of drama was
like between the gorgas and teresa like
they're back to being
uh on thin ice which is always they're
always walking on eggshells around each
other what did you think about joe
burga's response at the comedy show
about louie's video
i mean it's just funny but like the
thing is
i don't know how to how
joe and melissa like put up with theresa
and her insane double standards so like
i understand you're not always gonna say
the right thing i don't know was that
the right thing to say about your sister
i don't know but at the end of the day
you know what's so funny is
teresa's not eat teresa's so like
obsessed with herself she's not even mad
at joe like on watch what happens live
the kids are mad at joe but she was like
well joe was defending me you know
family over everything like she like is
so obsessed with like you have to defend
me family family family she doesn't even
care that her kids are mad at their
uncle like she actually doesn't give a
[ __ ]
yeah i mean it's a hard spot to be in
for theresa not that i think she's
handling it well i don't know what else
she could do but like joe gorga isn't
wrong in his assessment of joe jodice
but
that is his niece's the father so like
to say those things on television is
really harmful
but we're all do you remember that
episode jackie what episode
where he said it like they were i think
they were at the jersey shore they were
at laura's house like teresa was being
so unreasonable like how any human being
couldn't erupt like i'm sorry i totally
understand yeah no i agree like it it's
unfortunate that like that's it's on the
show and and now they have to live
through it and this like feud is public
but that's the truth what he said was
the truth and like when you push it like
if you want to keep bringing it up and
you want to push it he's just gonna you
know spew that so it's it's an
unfortunate situation i think um
because the girls are so upset about it
but he wasn't lying so
no no yeah and yeah
um
but yeah i thought it was a good episode
i enjoyed it and i'm looking forward to
the season it should be good
yes me too i am i'm into it i'm i miss
the ladies
me too
um and that's our show anything else you
want to talk about before we head out oh
i did finish drag race i just want to
say like cornbread is great i know i
threw my support behind her but like i
think that angeria
might be one of the best queens who's
ever graced the stage that's all i'll
say and she definitely could win willow
pill too
okay but say it with caution because you
don't want to you know do your classic
curse yeah i know
totally
um thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning toast the millennial
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
monday through friday here on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found set spotify itunes
stitch or public radio i heart radio
cast box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcasts find out some morning
chose and leave a five star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing hump day
don't forget to hump someone you love
jackie make sure to tell everyone that
you love them because people were really
distraught that you didn't do it
yesterday
love you guys bye